From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is Emily Crosby on December 9, 2015 with Judy Richardson and we're in her home in Silver Spring, Maryland, outside of DC.
And we're here with the Civil Rights History Project, co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And also with us are John Bishop and Lou Haas-Shanker. Judy, thank you so much for doing our interview.
Thank you. Can you start by telling us when and where you were born and about your family?
I was born on March 10, 1944 in Tarrytown, New York, which is about 45 miles north of New York City.
My mother, Melee Louise Richardson, newly Tucker, was first a seamstress and then a homemaker.
Married to my father and my father was a... Oh, and also she was a jazz pianist, but I can get to that in a minute.
Yeah, oh, honey, played a mean jazz piano. But my father was William King Richardson and he grew up in the house that I grew up in and that he married and took my mother to in Tarrytown and the under the hill section.
It's called that of Tarrytown, which is where all the blue collar folks lived right near the railroad tracks.
My father had helped to organize the United Auto Workers' Local in what was called the plant, which was the Fisher Body Chevrolet Plant, where my father and the fathers of everybody I knew worked.
And you could tell time from the shifts changing at the plant.
And I found out only after my older sister saw a one of the many documentary series that Blackside had done after I was on the prize and it was on the depression.
And the beginning segment of that was on the beginnings of the Ford Factory. That was the first segment.
And she saw all of the archival material from that and what it looked like in the plant. And she called me and she said, oh, I just saw Blacksides and it reminded me of when Daddy was organizing the local.
And this is news to me. So I said, what? And she said, yeah, Daddy was working in the plant and she said there were times when he had decided he wanted to organize a union and the UAW local there.
And so she said what I remember, what she, my sister remembered, was that when the guy from the nationally was a white guy.
And so he would come up and sit in my kitchen talking to my father. And what my sister said was that my mother would immediately close the curtains because we were ground level.
We had a little teeny tiny little house right on the ground there. And she said she would immediately close the curtains so that nobody could see that my father was talking to somebody from the local, from the national.
Because she was afraid of course with good reason that he might lose his job.
Did you have a sense of the time? I have this.
Not really. I mean, I have no memory of it. And so it would have had to be when he, so he dies on the assembly line when I'm seven years old. He dies of a heart attack.
And so that would have been probably 53, 4 and 7 is 11, 51, 51. So I was seven years old and he, oh, when the other thing she remembers about this is that sometimes people would leave groceries, bags of groceries on our porch.
Because they would be too afraid to overtly say they were supporting the local and the building of the organizing of the local.
But the way they did that was to then give my family some groceries.
And so I'll keep my sister, Carita said, you know, you would come down outside and you would find these bags of groceries on the porch.
And the result was that as one of the white guys in Tarry Town mentioned to me when we were protesting segregated housing, why are you doing this? He said, we loved Billy, my father, which they did. They loved Billy.
Now they wouldn't allow him and some other stuff, but they loved Billy because he had, you know, he was treasure of that local when he died of a heart attack on the line, you know, in 51.
So yeah, there's all of that. So your dad's helping to organize a union that's mostly white and he wants to be?
No, there weren't no, no, because Tarry Town had a, I would say about a 10% black population. And like all of the white ethnic on our block, because my block, there was the projects down the road. And that was just about all black.
And then on our block, which again was under the hill, so we nobody had any money, but they were all working class, my family, and then the working class, white people on the block, Italians, Polish, and Irish.
And so in addition though, and I should mention by the way that Tarry Town was steeped in tradition. So I went to Washington Irving, junior high school. This was Washington Irving's territory.
Washington Irving's, Washington Irving, junior high school, sleepy hollow high school. Yes, our mascot was the headless horseman, a horseman goat. It was all of that. I mean, we had, you know,
and, but I didn't see any middle class, certainly no middle class black people, but no middle class white people either, because it hadn't become that kind of suburban thing.
There were white people who lived in sleepy hollow manner and tap and see something like that. But most of the people I knew, and certainly all my friends, were white kids, some black kids, but mainly white kids whose parents, whose father worked in the plant,
the black people I knew their mothers mainly, their fathers worked in the plant too, and their mothers oftentimes worked out so they were domestic workers.
Yeah.
Well, I was just so when, when people are saying you really love Billy, why are you doing this kind of thing, that's because you're protesting segregation.
Segregated housing, housing, but also on my block at the end of my block was a fire department, and it was all volunteers. You know, I mean, it's Tarry Town.
And so they had no, I mean, none of the fire departments had any black people. So when I come back from SNCC, that first summer, which would have been 60, I guess the summer is 64 somewhere in there, not only have we already started a Tarry Town or civil rights, but also with this wonderful black couple, Ogalli, who was a doctor, oh, I may or may not remember her name.
She and her husband both, both black, she was the doctor, and he was an architect, and they moved on Broadway, and that was major.
I mean, when I went back to speak at Marymount College in Tarry Town, they came as did a number of former folks from Tarry Town as civil rights, and I went up to her husband, and I said, oh my gosh, you know you were the first black couple to actually make it to Broadway, you know, and he said, you know, all the black people told us that, you know, so it was great.
Yeah, but so we're doing stuff around residential, but it's also specific to that fire department. Now, when we pull up a picket line, it's on the end of my block, right, 133 Franklin Street was my town, right, was my address.
At the end of that block, we had a picket line, and it was at a corner where all the commuters, because there were commuters.
I just didn't know any of them because they were white in middle class, but they would come through that when they got off the train, because we're right across from the train, right.
So they would see the picket line, and we had thrown it up because, you know, they blackpoles, and they said that, we blackpoles, you know, and I remember one guy coming, oh what?
What does that mean for young people to know?
Yes, good point. Blackpoles, and during the certain times when we were trying to rearrange the language, we started calling it whitepoles.
But blackpoles meant that you did not, one blackpoles, it was kind of like you would put, well, I guess in terms of the fire department, it meant that if there was any neighborhood on a proposed person who would be invited in to be part of the city,
it would be part of the volunteer fire department.
Then somebody would either put a black ball, or put a black piece of paper, something to indicate, nay.
But the ball, oftentimes I guess how it started, was that it would be a ball, it would be a little black ball that would mean that was a no vote.
Did that automatically look any blackpoles?
Yes, and what they reminded me of, and this was while I'm on the picket line, they reminded me that, first of all, yes, we loved Billy.
But also, that when our house caught fire, Thanksgiving day, and we had gone out of town to my father's family, and in Yonkers, nearby, came back and found smoldering.
I mean, they hit, it was just, and one of them, my mother reminded me of this. She said that one of the firemen who loved Billy, said, you know,
I stopped one of the other firemen from using a hatchet on the door, because I said, no, this is Billy's house.
And I'm sure he did that, because that was separate.
So, yeah, with smoldering, you know, remember we all, you know, were in there, it was cold, because we couldn't put any heat on.
But eventually, I got back to whatever, and it didn't burn down, it just was very smoldering, and we couldn't have any heat.
And it was thanksgiving and cold and stuff, yeah. So anyway, there were fond memories of my father.
And we also picketed, again, after I come back from that first stint in SNIC.
So I'm taking a break, we're fundraising for SNIC. And it must have been, I can't remember if it was before or after the 64 Summer Project and Mississippi.
But certainly, we're doing some kind of fundraising. And so I bring Stokely, the Freedom Singer, so Bernice and Chuck and Rutha.
And I don't know who the other, who was the other, in that original group, it wasn't Matthew, who's the other guy?
Oh, and Cordell, yeah, Cordell, hello. So they come up, and they, so Stokely speaks.
Now this is before Black Power, so it's 64. Stokely speaks, the Freedom, SNIC Freedom Singer's sing, and it's in Patriots Park in front of the library.
There was a woman, Mrs. Kenny, who was as right wing as you could get her. And so she protested about how in Patriots Park, there were these Communists singing these songs, and we all know they were Communists.
She had written the letter saying that SNIC was a Communist, well, basically what did they used to call them, not supporters.
Sympathizer, yeah. And so she put this in the Tarry Town Daily News. Now my mother wrote, I mean, she had a beautiful handwriting. I mean, it was gorgeous.
My mother had like an eighth grade education, right. She read everything. Every Sunday it was meet the press on the television.
I remember her, she had stacks of the New York Post, which then was a real newspaper, right. And she would love Mary Kempton's articles because he was a little leftist, he was a liberal, basically.
And so she had all these stacks on her in her bedroom. And she would write back to Mrs. Kenny in the Tarry Town Daily News and say, no, you know, did it, did it, and very rational.
Mrs. Kenny at one point said something about which I had to respond to, but had said something about we know that they are coming to Sympathizers because it was read into the Congressional record.
And it's like you could be the phone book into the Congressional record, but she didn't know any better.
So there was always that kind of, you know, it's kind of like the Tea Party now, you know, that's it.
So, but my mother would, you know, respond. And then I have letters from her, you know, where she's saying that I shouldn't, I should be careful and not, you know, be around people because I'm going to be, I'm going to get a cold.
And she said, stay away from anybody who's sneezing because I've just realized that's part of what got lost at that Duke interview.
But I have the original letter from her where she talks about, you know, staying away from anybody who's cold, you know, who has a cold in the sneezing.
And then she says, now, of course, this is, I'm in Mississippi and it's 1964. And she's talking about worry about the people who were sneezing because they may give you a cold.
And then, really thinking about that. Well, then her next line is something about, you know, I got to get to bed now. I haven't been sleeping well.
And it was only after I got grown and looked at this letter, not back then, that I realized she's not sleeping because she's worried sick about me, right?
But she's not saying any of that in the letter. And she says in the letter something about, you know, and key to my sister, Carita, is cooking, can Duke Thanksgiving dinner because she's organizing parties.
Now, the parties were that I had brought my sister in and my sister was now organizing the Harry Belafonte parties in 1964 on Long Island out of the SNCC fundraising office in New York City.
And so my sister who could really cook, unlike my mother, excuse me, my sister could cook. And so she was going to usually could do the turkey, but no, she's doing the Belafonte concerts.
Yeah.
So, how do I go back?
Yes.
Sorry, no, I go off.
You know, but so you found out later from your sister that your father was organizing.
Yes.
And you died on the line in your seven.
And what was your mother doing?
Yes, good point.
So, my mother, at some point my mother, well, my mother could play piano.
I mean, she could hear something and could just do chords.
And so she had written music. She read certainly read scores and stuff, but she'd music.
And she loved working in best. She had all that sheet music in the bench.
But in addition, she could play all kinds of things. And she loved, you know, Oscar Peterson.
And she just loved lots of people. So, mm-hmm.
Not Oscar, be artedim. She loved artedim.
So, for her own amusement, she is doing this.
But before I'm born, I think, before I'm born.
She was the pianist in a little jazz combo in Westchester County, which is where Terry Tendless.
And so she was going around playing as the pianist with this Teddy Whiteley Orchestra.
Until my father stopped it.
And I guess he didn't want his wife going off when he was not there on site, you know,
and off to these little clubs and stuff.
Oh, jazz.
You got it.
A little free, yes. Although my mother was so prim. But anyway, so.
So, in any event, so she's not doing that, but she's still always played.
I mean, I always remember my mother playing to the point that when I come back from,
and I got to tell you about the numbers because she also booked the numbers.
But when I come back from 64 from Mississippi,
she's sitting in our little living room on the bench and in front of the piano.
And it was a little small piano.
And she said, come here, come here.
And I go over and I sit next to her on the bench.
And she started playing. We shall overcome with these blue chords.
I still remember it. It's like it just brought tears to me.
You know, it was like, oh, my little mommy.
You know, it was so cute. It was so cute.
And they were so gorgeous. I mean, I had never heard.
We shall overcome that way. You know, it's just, it was just gorgeous.
Yeah. And she, I mean, she had heard it.
It wasn't like she was reading, you know, sheet music.
She just heard the chords, you know.
And so also though, what my mother did was that she booked numbers.
So since she wasn't playing in the orchestra anymore.
And she booked numbers for including, well, for everybody.
Now, I'm in an ethnic neighborhood, right?
So, and the mayor is Italian, mayor of Atlanta.
Well, his mother used to come down from up the hill.
And she would come down and she would book the numbers.
Not every day. Some people did it every day.
But she booked it every so often.
And then, you know, walk back up the hill and stuff.
And a lot of the people booked numbers with my mother
or my father also booked it at the plant.
And so, and then Trippi, who was this tall white guy,
Trippi was the runner.
So he would bring in the slips. He would take the money, you know.
And I think people felt comfortable doing it with my mother
because she was honest as hell, you know, as was my father.
Now, my sister told me that my father once got arrested
for and had the number of slips on him.
And my sister said she was so embarrassed
because it was in the Tarry Town Daily News.
Yes. And now, what was funny about that was
everybody booked with my father.
So somebody must have wanted something,
somebody didn't get a pay off, something.
Because it was like the Italian folk, the Irish folk,
the Italian Irish Polish folk, everybody booked with my father.
You know, so...
Oh, I'm sorry.
Now, the number is...
I just found out recently that it was otherwise known as the...
What are these? The Italian lottery.
So if you look it up, and some people suggested it came in
through the Italian immigrants who first come in.
But so it is otherwise known as that.
But the numbers were based...
The ones I knew were based on the race.
And certain races that were being played that day, that day.
And so it was a three-digit number.
You could combine it, you could do, you know, four, five, three, three, five, four, you know, however.
And it was called boxing it.
And it was simple enough so that people could understand it.
But I didn't quite get all of the stuff around it.
I just knew it was based on that day's race.
You know, which in that day's race.
And that people would then come to collect, you know, if they won the numbers.
And...
So, and then, you know, my mother would get a cut off whatever,
particularly if somebody won who had bet with her.
And then people would tip you and, you know, all of a sudden.
One time my mother bet.
And I always remember this because she told me this story.
She said, she won. And she then called my aunt Helen, her sister, who lived in the Bronx.
They were close. I mean, they were so close that every day I would call my aunt Helen,
only for four, four, nine, eight, six.
I would call her every night because my mother would say, call Helen.
And I'd go, okay, close, close.
My mother wins.
And she then calls my aunt Helen and says, Helen, get ready. I'm going to pick you up.
We're going to go buy some fur coats.
So she and my mother got these fur coats from whatever my mother had played in one.
So, yeah.
What kind of work did your mother do after your father died?
Well, you know, I mean, it was great, first of all, when my father died.
Now, they're hearing your questions, right?
Okay, fine.
When after he died, what was great about the unions, of course,
is that they were pensions for the family.
So my mother has a modicum of, you know, a small amount,
but she also knows she has to work.
Oh, let me, isn't that fact?
Let me tell you what she does with that small amount of money,
because she realized she needed a car.
And so she was going to buy a car and, you know, pay for it over time.
The only one of the two times that I had ever seen my mother talk about race
was this time when she goes to buy a car, it was going to be a valiant.
And she buys this, she goes and comes back and she is huffing man.
Because the man is obviously, the white salesman has obviously disrespected her
and suggested that she does not have the money to buy this.
She comes back, she takes all of the money out that would,
for the, not just the down payment, but to pay for the car outright
and gives it to the man.
So that, you know, it was an inroad and whatever might have been there.
But that money was there because, you know, they didn't spend much money on stuff.
But also because, you know, there was a UAW pension that just went to her.
However, that wasn't enough.
And so she then gets a job.
Oh, well, first of all, she goes for, you had to get on a list.
So you had to take an exam.
Now my mother was very smart.
She had an eighth grade education, but she was really smart and corrected my grammar.
Because, I mean, I would say, well, he went with Henry and me.
She said, no, with Henry and I, she said me, Henry and me.
She always is the preposition.
She knew the parts of the, you know, it was all of that.
So even to my, even now, I correct my grammar based on my mother standing over my shoulder, right?
But so she knew all this stuff, but she kept getting low marks.
And you had to be in the top whatever number to be considered for a county job.
She goes to Mr. Slaven who ran the drugstore and says to Mr. Slaven, you know, I can't seem to get hired.
She said, it seems to me that I'm coming up at the top of the exam.
But nobody's calling me for work.
He says, Mr. Slaven says, how are you registered?
And she says, Democrat.
You got to change your registration.
Be a Republican.
And she does, and I always remember this, immediately.
She gets called.
And so then she becomes a county worker as a secretary at the county office building in White Plains.
So she's doing that every day.
You said one or one or two times, you're not going to talk to them?
Oh, good pick up.
Yes.
Which I would not have remembered.
So thank you.
The other time was when she mentioned going to see Birth of a Nation in whatever that would have been 1915 or something during President Wilson's presidency.
And she said that she went in and for those who don't know, the birth of a nation was based on the book.
Should I go through all that?
Yeah.
Okay.
Based on a book written by Klansman.
It valorized the clan.
And just said, you know, basically they were the protectors of White womanhood after reconstruction.
And that's the reason why people were safe in the South.
Okay.
So, and they absolutely make horrible.
They make the, it's the whole cool thing and ignorant and rapist as the former enslaved people.
So, and, but what film courses do with this film is that they really teach it as for the technique because it was a new technique.
And sometimes they don't even mention how racist it was.
Okay.
So, I've gone to film departments.
And, okay, so I know about this.
But the, what she remembered was that she had gone with a friend of hers.
And she said she saw the way the black people were portrayed.
And by the way, I should mention that, well, I'm sorry.
The way they were portrayed.
And she said, I couldn't even lift my head.
She said, we came out of that theater and all I could do was look down at the pavement.
I was so ashamed.
Never talked about the larger issue of racism or any of that.
That was the incident.
That's what I learned.
Now, I later find out when we're doing eyes on the prize.
And I mentioned to John Dindmer.
I said, you know, I saw this when I was the only black person in my AP history course at Sleepy Hollow High School.
And I loved the course.
But we were doing something on reconstruction.
And I said the only, of course it was, I mean, just a short piece on reconstruction.
But it was so negatively portrayed.
And in fact, the only illustration was the one that came from birth of a nation,
which I find out.
But I didn't know what that was.
I just knew it was an illustration and it showed what was supposed to be a white scala wag.
And they were, the black eye was disheveled and he had his feet on the desk of the,
what was supposed to be the state legislature during reconstruction.
And you see the white guy who's come down from the north and he looks horrible, you know.
And the whole framing of it was as a really negative thing.
So you didn't get anything about South Carolina, you know, first time you get free public education for poor whites as well as black people, you know, all that.
So I mentioned to its eyes on the prize school.
It's say, eyes one would have been somewhere around mid 80s.
And one of our advisors was John Dindmer, who does local people, right? But hadn't done it yet.
And so I say to John, you know, John, I remember this book and it had this illustration in it of what was supposed to be black reconstruction.
And I said, when we looked at it and you saw that horrible caricature, all I remember is the white kids in my class kind of looking back at me, you know, kind of trying not to look but always looking back.
And I felt really ashamed. I mean, as my mother had with the same, you know, semi same imagery, that's it.
So I say so and the thing is what they were denied was the same thing I was denied, which was the reality of what black reconstruction really was.
And the sense that I got coming out of that, which was this is what happens when black people are put into any position of authority or control.
Right. So I get that message, oh my god, classmates get that. And that's so I asked John, John Dindmer, what am I remembering this? And he said, oh yeah, that was and he remembered the authors.
And he said that was a nationally prescribed textbook at the time.
So other people are getting this, you know, so anyway, I can't remember how I started out. Oh, because that's it. So that's that's the other part of that was that imagery.
So it's never just a film. People will tell me, why are you getting soft set like with Mississippi burning? Why are you getting soft set? It's just a film. It's never just a film. You know, so yeah.
So you covered a lot of different things about the only thing I remember talking once and you telling me the letter to the editor about the little last thing.
Yes, I did. I forgot that. Yes.
So I'm in high school. So somewhere between 10th grade and 12th grade. So wait, 57. Okay. So 57, 44. What is that 13?
I do. It's just something here. Okay.
And I remember writing a letter, which was to tell the Tarotan Daily News, I don't know why these students in Little Rock are trying to get into this white school.
They're better off just pursuing their education however they want because it's really about education and we will progress through that.
So how far we've come?
Yes, exactly. That's right. That's exactly. That's right. Yeah.
Yeah. So it was, you know, I mean, until I get to sneak. It could have been my mother. You know, it could have been, but I should not blame my mother for this.
It could have been other folks in the school. I mean, since that's what I got when I'm at Swarthmore, good Quaker College, when we're doing the desegregating and good Quaker children is saying to us, you'd be better off not doing any demonstrating, but staying on campus.
And just pursuing your education as one of the students said to somebody else, they would be better doing that because they'll be, oh, no, how did he put it?
Because they will be able to contribute more to their race. That was the thing. Yes. So I mean, that was the general line of thinking of most people, most white people and some black people too, but most white people.
So I can see that I would have incorporated that, you know, given that I'm sitting there. Yeah.
Do you have anyone that's looking up and compare how much you've contributed and who's contributed?
Oh, that one. No. No, forget him. Exactly.
So let's jump ahead and you just mentioned you go to college at Swarthmore. So how do you end up at Swarthmore and what's it like?
I was one of eight black students who come into Swarthmore that year. So that was 62. Now, I was in the top three. I mean, there were three of us who were in the top as we graduated, had small graduating class.
And I applied to Bennington where my sister had gone.
Brinmore, I think, Adiach and Swarthmore. And Bennington actually, because my sister had not done that well at Bennington.
And so Bennington says, well, we can, we will admit you, but we're not going to give you the money that we understand Swarthmore is giving and that we understand they really are going to be doing.
However, they said this in their letter. You got it. And then I get the Swarthmore letter and the Swarthmore letter says full freight for four years. Now my mother obviously had no money.
So I'm thinking, oh, okay, I guess I'll do Swarthmore. So I come in as one of eight four boys, four black kids.
This is all incoming freshman class.
Four black men, four black women. I assumed it was so that we would not have to date outside our little group. All of eight of us.
Oh, yeah, immediately. Yeah, of course.
But the main thing was that we were also all housed with Quaker children.
And the assumption being, I think, that the Quaker children would be more accepting of us. Right.
So I got made, who was, I can't remember, makes last name.
Let me just say that was not automatically true once we started doing demonstrations.
But when we come in, it's eight and it's four and four. And when I come in, there are maybe two other black students there.
One was a senior and one was a sophomore to my remember, at least my memory. That's what I've got.
Somebody when I said this, we had an all day meeting when we did our hands on the Freedom Plow all day at Swarthmore.
And I think the president or somebody may have said they thought there was a third and that that was an African student.
But I'm not sure because I've never checked the records.
Anyway, so we come in and I had been, you know, I mean, a senior year always is, you know, you've been sliding through.
I come into Swarthmore and it's like, oh my god.
And not only is it academically really pressurized, but it's also that most of these kids have come out of, you know, Sidwell Friends.
I mean Quaker schools come out of private schools, you know, which now are called independent schools.
I'm coming from a good public high school, but they've also come from families where they wintered in Paris, you know.
And I had been to Albany, you know, that was New York, New York, excuse me, Albany, New York.
And that was my one and only plane ride before this.
And that was only because I was part of the all-state youth orchestra, which went to, or was that Buffalo?
We went to Buffalo. Sorry, Buffalo.
So, you know, these were worldly young kids, which was why I was so amazed when we did the demonstrations and they turned against us.
But some of them, not all of them.
So anyway, so I come in and, you know, and I'm, as usual, very good in English, but it's like even Paulie Psy, which was an 8 a.m. on a Saturday course, with a professor who was phoning it in.
You know, it's like, and I'm, you know, I'm not a morning person.
8 a.m. on a Saturday, and it's like he's reading from his notes, please.
But it was in that Paulie Psy class that I got to respect this one young guy who knew about Lenin and Trotsky and all this stuff that I had never heard of before.
He's the one who says, I overhear him saying once we do the demonstrations, you know, they'd be better off sticking to education.
Oh, yeah. They're my little theorist who I just thought was so amazing because he knew all this stuff, right?
Yes, because they'll be a better credit. They'll be able to do more for their race. Yes.
Were you aware of the sitting in the Freedom Rage before you go to college?
I was not, and that's so surprising to me. You know, it's like I probably even knew maybe Emmett Till, but I don't remember it because I'm sure for given my mother,
although we had a weekly subscription to Jet Magazine, but I don't remember seeing that then, unless I just blocked it out, or she made sure I didn't see that issue.
I don't know because I do remember reading the jet.
It did, but I don't remember any of that.
So, I don't remember any stuff, you know.
And then I get, so that's why I'm not really sure what really would draw us me to the SDS meeting, but I don't know if you want to get to that yet.
So, how? So, you're in your first year at Swarthmore?
Yeah. And you end up at a SDS meeting?
Yes. And the SDS chapter was called SPAC, the Swarthmore Political Action Committee.
And the co-chairs were that, of that, were Mimi Fine Gold and Carl Whitman.
Now, Mimi, I did not know until 2010 when I go back to Swarthmore for this all day, hands on the Freedom Plow Meeting conference, whatever event.
And I go back and I decide I need to look up who Mimi was.
And I found out that she had done six weeks in parchment prison on the Freedom Rides before she comes back to be co-chair of SPAC.
Didn't know that. When I'm looking at her, I knew nothing about her background.
So, she was a core person, she was on core staff.
She later goes into Placaman County, deadly Placaman County, Louisiana.
Didn't know any of that. But mainly, I did not know that she had done the six weeks in parchment before I see her standing up at a SPAC meeting.
Her co-chair, Carl Whitman, later after he leaves Swarthmore, they get married.
That didn't work out too well. He was gay. And then he then becomes big in the gay rights movement.
And he does this big treatise that people use.
So, it's like they were leaders then. And at this point, they were really doing a lot around...
SPAC had three main things. One was organizing the all black cafeteria staff for better working conditions, better pay, health conditions, all that stuff.
And then I'll get back to that. Second was doing tutorials in Chester, Pennsylvania, which is still has the PITS school.
Just horrible, primarily black schools. So, they were doing tutorials.
And then the third thing was doing helping Gloria Richardson and CNAC, the Cambridge Nonviolent Action Committee, a SNCC affiliate, with opening up the all the segregated public facilities.
Cambridge Black folks had had the votes since the 40s, but now they were opening up the trying to desegregate the public facilities.
So, it was those three things. It was the black cafeteria staff and the tutorial in Chester, Pennsylvania and Cambridge, Maryland.
So, all black cafeteria staff, I'm work study. So, it's hard for young people to understand what something like Swarthmore was like.
I mean, it was gorgeous. Still gorgeous. So, the dining hall with this gorgeous dining hall with these big old wooden tables, and we all sat around it, and we were served.
Nobody had to bust their own tables. You never thought of that, right? So, the waitresses would come in, and they would not only serve you, but they would take the stuff back.
The place back, well, I was one of the waitresses in the evening. I think maybe two or three nights, because I was work study, you know, as part of my four-year vol, you know, tuition paid.
So, one of the things that the black cafeteria staff had been trying to get was covering on this open, it was a big hot water pipe that was right on one of the walls.
And so, they would, in the rush to go back and forth in the dining hall, they would sometimes back into it, and they would get cinched on their leg.
Swarthmore never did anything about it, right? So, that was one of the grievances they had. Okay, I'm moving back and forth. I hit it.
And I swear to God, I had H2O backwards on my inner thigh. Oh, yeah, four years. Oh, it was amazing. Now, of course, the college is really worried about me. So, when it happens, I remember Mimi saying, you got it, I'm a student.
And I don't have to worry about whether I sue them, because I'm not working. You know, it's like, okay, so I remember Mimi saying to me, we've got to figure out, I mean, she was really concerned that I was okay. I mean, there was that.
But the other thing was, how can we use this to open up stuff for the rest of the really working, you know, cafeteria staff? So, I remember being called into some...
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I should have mentioned that before, because it's how I get there. But anyway, yes, and I'll go back to how I get there.
So, she says, this is what we're going for, and there was this wonderful woman whose name I can't remember from the black cafeteria staff, it's like I'm doing trays.
And she would come to our meetings, and she often brought some other black, usually female workers, because I think it might have been all female.
I don't know who was in the kitchen, but in terms of the weight staff, I'm pretty sure it was all black female.
Anyway, she was amazing, because I had in one of my old iris, I had that she had, you know, she was coming in how amazing she was and just, you know, and just smart as a whip, you know, it's just...
So, anyway, so I remember being called into some administrative office, the Deans of Somebody, who is clearly very nervous about the fact that I have gotten, you know, this thing.
Yes, this injury, and they want to know what I'd want, and so I have been schooled by Mimi about, you know, well, this is what we need, and if I remember correctly, we got some of it.
But it was also because this weight staff really was strong. I mean, they were really amazing and stuff.
And, you know, I'm sure Swarthmore was aware of its quaker, you know, heritage, and, you know, it looked bad.
Little pressure. Little pressure. That's right, exactly. Yes, that's it.
And so, but the reason I first start going to the meetings is that it really is because, you know, I sometimes say it's because my mother's not there to stop me.
I'm sampling everything. I'm a freshman, it's like, what can I get into, what's going on, you know, it's tough.
So, I happen to... I don't know who told me about it, but somebody mentions it, or I see a leaflet, and I said, let me just try this, you know.
And I get deeper and deeper into it. That's the thing. I have no idea what you're always me.
But for the first time, I see somebody actually protesting some of this stuff. You know, I mean, it's like, I think in the back of my mind, I always knew there were things going on.
But it's not something my mother would raise. It's not something I was talking about when I was at Tarrytown, but...
And maybe it was cumulative. You know, finally, at this point, you know, it's 62-63. Maybe I'm actually waking up to some of the racial stuff. I don't know.
But I go to this thing, and they are so amazing to me. I mean, Mimi was just amazing. Carl somewhat, but it was Mimi who I really...
Because she was just energetic, and you know, it was amazing.
So, you know, we do whatever we do with them. But anyway, so I go to this meeting, I find out what their agenda, you know, what programs are working on.
And then, through them, I go to the... That first bus ride going down to Cambridge, Maryland. So I sign up for the bus ride.
Is this what we call?
And so, weekend. That's right. Because the guarantee was that you would go down on a Saturday, and you would come back Sunday night.
And you would do picket lines. And the guarantee was that you would come back Sunday night, so you would be there for Monday classes.
And this is going to Cambridge, Maryland, which I think was maybe about two and a half hours away.
And we're smart, more students doing like how are students doing the burden student money and for supporting movement with buses and rollercoats?
Oh, that's interesting. I don't know. You know, because I really am new. So I don't really know what Mimi was doing. I just get on the bus. That's exactly it. I get on the bus.
And we were one of many colleges from the area who were going down.
So you would get there and it wouldn't just be Swarthmore College students. It would be... Because I remember Mark Suckle, who later goes down into the National Office.
He's coming from someplace. You would see Morgan State folk. And I don't remember the Howard people, but I remember some of the other nearby.
Galture, I remember, was coming down.
So this is spring fall?
No, oh, I see. Okay, I get in. So it would be fall. Probably late fall.
62. That's right. Yeah.
And what was it like to go to Cambridge and participate in the picket?
I have certain memories. And so that's really it.
What I remember is the first... One of the first demonstrations. I'm not sure if it was the first.
I remember we were trying to integrate the chop tank in.
And I remember being enough close that I could see inside the end.
And it was at Old Barn Grill. It was dirty. It was dank. It smelled... I always say I've brought Galture liquor.
I mean, it's just nasty.
And I'm thinking, why am I trying to get in here?
It's like this is a nasty place.
No, exactly. Under normal circumstances. Yes, okay.
But it was like, I see this big, burly white guy. Who's telling me, I can't come in.
Close on black. And I see him. And it's like, you're telling me.
I can't, you know, it was stupid. So at a certain point, we start getting arrested.
No, right.
Well, in many ways I did, but with this thing, no, it was clear. That was clear.
So I then, either there or we were also trying to integrate the skating rink.
Which, you know, in everybody, I skated at that. And it was our roller, and it was a roller rink too.
Is that in Cambridge?
In Cambridge, right in Cambridge. And that was the source of it initially.
Because the reason Gloria Richardson, who is at that point, the overleader.
I mean, she's the one who most of the media knows. But as she often said, this was a, you know, this was group leadership in Cambridge.
And so there were a lot of people who were part of the main committee and stuff.
But Gloria, it's her daughter and the young people in Cambridge who decide they want to integrate the roller.
I used to know the name of it, but the rink, the skating rink.
And so Gloria and one of her maybe relatives, it might have been her cousin and laws, a matter of fact.
But in any event, the two women go down to SNCC. Because they decide they need help in terms of how to organize demonstrations.
And Gloria said, you know, she put on little white glows and they had heels and stuff.
And of course they walk into the national divorce, the physical and everybody's and jeans and overalls, you know, stuff. But they had their little gloves.
And so Ku Klits sent as a SNCC field secretary, is Reggie Robinson. And he's the one I first meet as a SNCC person when I go in.
But the reason they choose the roller rink is because it's the young people. And Gloria said, you know, it was her daughter who said, you know, we're tired of this.
And but the older people knew we don't know how to quite do this. We don't want the young people going crazy.
And so we need to figure out how to organize this. But also Gloria was, you know, her family was well known.
Both among the black people and the white people. And so, you know, she and her family had the drugstore.
They had various businesses. Pop Herb, whom I stayed with overnight when I would come down. Pop Herb was the funeral parlor.
So, what did a lot of people do? I remember a lot of people. But that it went off and on. You know, it wasn't always that.
But in terms of Pop Herb and as the funeral director, he would put a bail for us.
There would be people who would stay in his attic, because our members staying there. Mark, I remember was there. There were other people, you know, we would, how we would be housed up there.
And yeah. So, yeah.
And you said, Reggie Robinson was the first Nickerson unit.
Yeah.
And Gloria is the visible leader in Cambridge. Do you remember what your impressions were of them?
Yes. And before I forget what I meant to say before I got into who was, who was staying there.
One of the things that was clear with Gloria, and we can get into this later, but I want to, well, I'm thinking about it, was that she was never philosophically nonviolent.
And in fact, she said when her daughter said, you know, when she's bringing people in and stuff, her daughter says specifically to Gloria,
you can't come on the picket line because you're going to hit somebody.
And Gloria said she knew that was true. And it said, I'm sorry, and it said in fact that one time she said, she saw white guys whom she knew.
She said, I knew these guys. I grew up here. They grew up here. They're calling me name. She said so when the picket line ended, when one of, when they started leaving, she said, I tripped one of them.
So that was Gloria. Yeah. It was not only that she wasn't philosophically nonviolent.
She wasn't even tactically nonviolent. No, except on the line. She understood that on the line, I will be tactically.
But her main thing was when the demonstrations are gone, all bets are off. And she said if they come on our side of race street, because race street was a dividing line between white and black and Cambridge, Maryland, she said, I can't guarantee one way or the other. They're safety.
Yeah. Yeah. And Cambridge, of course, became kind of notorious for some of the battles. Yes. But you were there for that. I was not there for that. And I resent. I sometimes resent the way the history says it, which is, you know, it's when Stokeley goes in that suddenly or rap goes in that suddenly everything goes.
Those people were never philosophically nonviolent. You know, and so yeah. They were always protecting the black community when the white took come on rampage. Yes. That's correct. They were like Birmingham on Birmingham Hill. Same thing, which was the black community protected its community.
If you come in here and so Cambridge did the same thing when people when the white vigilantes, the white domestic terrorists came through, then you would find that black people and white people knew that that black people did have their guns and they would shoot them. I mean shoot at them.
So you said that you're trying things out because you're away from home and do you remember how you felt participating in the cities?
I felt amazing. I mean, I really did. I felt it was such energy to me to be part of, I mean, part of, if I had done it by myself, it would be one thing.
But it was like I was part of this group, the young people who were my age. And a lot of them were black. I mean, that was the thing when I get into SNCC. Well, anyway, a lot of them are, you know, are doing something about the stuff that I have sublimated all of my life in Tarotan.
I mean, I knew black people couldn't move anywhere on the other, on Broadway or the other side of it. I knew that. But it was a given. I knew that I didn't see any black businesses. I didn't see this. I didn't see anything in terms of Tarotan, aside from my father and other people, you know, going to the plant.
There were no black, there was no black middle class in Tarotan. The one time we got somebody who actually had money was when Chris Cowlowe, a cab Cowlowe's daughter came in and she was in our senior class.
Or maybe our junior class because she didn't last long. They eventually moved her to a private school, I think.
But that was the first time I saw anybody who was middle class. So even seeing people who are running their own businesses as I saw on Cambridge and other black communities in the South, I didn't see any of that in Tarotan.
So this was amazing. First of all, I see black young people and white young people who are fighting this thing. We are so tight. The camaraderie is so amazing. I'm going to these mass meetings where people are singing these freedom scongs and it's like you lift up to another place.
I'm not religious. My mother read the Bible every Sunday but she hated organized religions. I never went to church except once we can mention. Well, let me just divert. I start going to the Baptist church, the white Baptist church in Tarotan.
I didn't last long. I go one summer and I think I came through maybe the camp. It might have started that way. My mother was very pleased because even though she could not handle organized religion for whatever reason, she never mentioned it, she was pleased that I was going to church.
Yes, that's what it was. It was Bible camp because it must have been because I remember I got a dollar for memorizing the books of the Bible. Genesis, Exodus, the Loviticus, the number of Sodoron, the Jewish Jewish Jewish Ruth. First and second Samuels, first and second Kings.
Yes, well, that was the only way I could remember it. That's exactly it. Yes, but I got this dollar. My mother was very pleased and I didn't. Anyway, but then I overheard some of the, because it was all white, I think I was the only black child.
Yes, and I hear some of the white people in the church. I don't know. I happened to just overhear this and I hear them saying that we have to be, they say, we have to be careful because we don't want too many black kids coming in because then we'll get overrun.
That was the last time I ever went to camp, I never went to church, my mother never said anything. That was it.
So now I'm now in Cambridge. It's this mass meeting, it's a black church and it's like, oh, okay, you know, because it's the songs. It's the songs and what they're preaching about, of course, is freedom and liberation.
I mean, it's all that stuff. So I get, you know, so when I go back to Swarthmore each Monday and then it becomes maybe each Sunday, then sometimes it becomes Monday because we get held over.
Then, well, when I go back, I'm taking all this back with me to campus, you know, and that energy I'll take him back with me.
So you're getting increased in the community with the protest, the demonstration related to campus and Cambridge.
And let me show you, I know you decide to take a year off school.
Okay, well, Penny Patch, who had been in her sophomore year, white student, she had gone down to Southwest Georgia.
And I had heard about her, but she was not when I first come in that first semester.
Second semester, she returns from all of any Georgia and the SNCC project.
And she hears that I've been from the SPAC people, that I have been going to the meetings. And so she comes into my dorm room.
And she said, look, I hear that, you know, you've been going to the meetings and the demonstrations. And, you know, you might want to think about taking off the next semester, which would have been the first semester of my sophomore year.
And working full-time with SNCC and Cambridge, Maryland.
And so, you know, I start thinking, she said, however, if you do decide to do this, you've got to apply, because I'm coming from the North.
If I were Sagan and Black, you know, wouldn't have been a problem. But so she says, if you do decide to do this, though, you've got to go buy Ruby Dars.
And that's what she meant. Ruby Dars, Smith Robinson, the amazing administrator in the National Office and Atlanta.
So I didn't know anything about Ruby Dars then. So I say, okay, well, let me see what happens, you know. So I think I went ahead and applied and then got confirmation that I have been accepted for this next, you know, for the...
And you're specifically applying to work in Kansas.
Yes.
And so you're going to live with the Richardson family, not your kin.
And actually, probably not that. I'm probably pop her because that's where I used to say, yeah.
And she's... So I get that I've been allowed to do this. And because I got back from SNCC that there's confirmation.
And so now the point is, how do I tell my mother that I'm thinking about doing this, right?
So I go to the hall phone because of course it's before cell phones, right? And I go to the hall phone and I call my mother and I tell her, you know, I frame it in the sense which I had done.
I contacted the administration. I was guaranteed that I was going to maintain my full four-year scholarship. Nothing would change.
I could come back in again. They were kind. They were cool with it.
So I tell her all this. And to me, she was amazingly calm. She asked some questions.
But then I hang up and I go back to my dorm room and I'm thinking, I'm over. I've made it through this. And I had been so worried about it, right?
I don't make it more than I... In my mind, I'm thinking 20 to 30 minutes. And I get call back to the hall phone. Somebody picked it up.
It calls me. I get to the phone and it is my older sister, nine years older than me, Carita, when we call Kita. And she is screaming at me over the phone.
Like, what are you thinking of? You can't do this. And at that point, I think she was working for Columbia Records in the A&R division in New York City.
And she said, you know, her main thing was you can't sacrifice your education for this.
But then somehow I convinced her. And I told her, I really have guaranteed that, you know, coming back, it's going to be okay. And somehow convinced her.
And so everybody's agreed. I can do this now. So I finished out, you know, the rest of that year. And then I had already accepted to do... To be a student, not intern, but a student worker at the nearby kind of halfway house.
It was for foster kids. And so as a counselor, student counselor there, that's how I made my money. I wanted to not do it. But then the person who had hired me had said, look, you know, it's too late for me to get somebody else now.
So I made it through that. And then I took the bus, you know, in the fall, September. And no, it was October, because I remember I still had the stub bus trip.
And I went down and went to Cambridge. But before I tell you that, I should say, because it reminds me of my mother driving me with my sister down to Swarthmore that first time.
And she had never gone to Bennington. But I could see through her eyes that this was just amazing. You know, I mean, this was...
She had no sense of what Swarthmore meant, that it was an illegal. She had no sense of that. But she did have a sense that this was prestigious.
You know, rolling hills. And they let me drive. Now, had I known how I... I mean, if I had been them, I would never have allowed me to drive.
Because, you know, at that point, I was... I've always driven fast. But I was, you know, 18, 19 years old at that point.
And I remember driving through the... either the Holland or the Lincoln tunnel. And at some point, I changed lanes. And I remember my sister saying, no, you can't change lanes on the time.
And I'm still... Okay, you know, so we get down there. And my sister was absolutely wonderful, because my sister could talk to anybody. I was very...
You know, I was shy in my own way. I mean, I didn't know how to deal with strangers. I worried about talking to people. And said, my sister didn't worry about any of that.
So she could talk to anybody, anywhere, whoever they were. So she talks to everybody in the dorm. She gets to me. She introduces me. This is my sister. You know, she's...
May comes in. My sister was the life of a party wherever she was. So I feel easier, because she has kind of paved the way for me.
And my mother, you know, my poor mother, because see, my sister left. So it was really my mother and I growing up for those last years.
And, you know, I was the baby. And it's like, you know, we were like this with my mother. And I...
I don't know how she made it. You know, for me it was like, oh, I'm in the strange world. And, you know, but she's gone back to an empty house. And I think about that now. You know, it just...
It must have been hard. Yeah. So anyway, so she goes back with Keeta and my sister, Carita, and, you know, and I'm there. And then, you know, get in. And during the school year, SPAC organizes not only this other stuff, but they decide to run a slate for the...
June, the May Queen. We did a May ceremony. That's right. It was the May Queen. And so it used...
It usually was, you know, the girlfriend of the football players. Or... No, no, not football, because they did outlaw football at that point.
Fract, all the Fract boys. Okay. So it was somebody's girlfriend. It was a sorority, sweetheart. It was somebody. But it would split the vote.
Well, with us, we ran a slate, the SDS slate. And we all block-voted. Right. So Mimi, head of SDS, you know, just got out of parchment, becomes the May Queen.
And I become one of the princesses, because that's what we were. And we had a little crown of little roses and stuff.
My mother comes down for it. She is so proud. She does not know that a number of the Fract boys and stuff are boycotting the ceremony.
She doesn't know that some of the people on the newspaper have mentioned... Have really, first of all, been absolutely death on our demonstrations.
And there are editorial policy and some of the reporting, including from one of the people, Elsa, Elsa, who was 16 when she comes on campus, was a friend of mine, had a total photographic memory. She was on my whole.
See, let me just go back and say, the demonstrations really split the campus. And so...
These are demonstrations on campus. No. That is correct. So these are the demonstrations in Cambridge, Maryland.
And these are the demonstrations where I hear this person from my polypsychlas, who says, you know, these black students would be better off doing...
He is part of a group of folks who normally liberal, I thought.
And so that is really coming out in the newspaper, in comments, because they are interviewing students who are saying again, the Negro students would be better off concentrating on their education.
That is right.
So when it gets to the point where... And we are getting arrested, you know, and all that stuff.
But now it is getting to the May Queen and we have taken over the ceremony, you know.
So a number of them don't come. Of course all of the kind of progressive kids come and we do this.
But the main thing is I am thinking about my mother. And she is just proud that she can be that there is her daughter with her little, you know, the roses and the...
And I introduce her to everybody. And you know, she had remembered it from being down there. But it is like, my mother was not traveled, you know.
And so she had gotten on the train, come down to, you know, buy herself. And she was just going to the city into New York. But she knew the city.
And this was, you know, this was new. And so, yeah, she was very proud.
Yes, she gave her a nice memory before you quit school.
Yes, exactly. That is right. Yes, it did. And she didn't know that that is what I was going to do. So it was okay.
That is right. So anyway. So she goes back, we continue the rest of it.
So you mentioned Mimi and how important she is. Mimi Fine Gold. And that she had been on the Freedom Rides in that spring 61, on her 61.
And then she is one of the leaders of the SDS chapter over there. She ends up in Louisiana with CORE.
Placaman Parish, that is right. And so do you have a sense of sort of how she ends up in CORE and you end up in SNCC for you to go into different directions?
The thing is, see, when she came back from the Freedom Rides, she was already CORE. When she comes back from Placaman Parish.
No, I am sorry. When she comes back from parchment, she is already CORE. I think... Freedom Rides.
I think it is the Freedom Rides. I don't know where she first took SDS with CORE. Because she is from Brooklyn. I don't know whether she is doing stuff with Arnie, whatever I can't remember.
But the Brooklyn CORE chapter was major.
I just find it interesting that you are on the same campus and you end up in the field with different civil rights organizations.
It is accepted. I am coming through Cambridge and she is not necessarily. She is already an activist before we go into Cambridge.
But she is still going to Cambridge. Absolutely.
That is not her introduction.
That is it.
I didn't even know about CORE but she was already that when I see her.
No wonder when she goes into the field.
Did she go to SNCC?
No.
No. I don't know whether... See, I am pretty sure that she continues her... Well, she was a senior.
So I think she leaves Cambridge. I mean, I am sorry. When she graduates. I am pretty sure that is when she goes into Placaman.
County in Louisiana.
I have been interested personally just in helping people getting a different...
Yes.
Sorry about the distress.
No, no.
So you have a commitment to a summer job so you go home and you do your summer job.
Then it is October and you head into Cambridge.
Yes.
And I continue doing the Cambridge work.
But truthfully, I have no real memory except demonstrations.
I have no memory of the job.
Demonstrations, getting arrested.
You know, it wasn't voter registration obviously because they had the voter ready.
So I am pretty sure most of that was demonstrations and organizing around that and getting adult community involved as much as the students.
Although they were pretty much already involved adults at that point.
So I don't really remember because see, I don't stay that long.
Because then by...
I go... It is a matter of fact, I hadn't thought about this.
I go down in October by November.
I am down in the Atlanta office.
Because what happens is that Reggie Robinson says,
look, I am going, I am taking the train to either Cleveland or Cincinnati.
I can't remember which.
Cincinnati.
Okay.
Because what is his name from Arkansas?
Bill Hansen.
And what?
Wait, from Southwest Georgia.
Oh God.
No, not from South... No, not from South Georgia.
It will come to me.
They are getting married.
Right.
And yeah, it will come.
Ruthie.
Ruthie Harris.
No.
Ruthie.
Well, Ruthie.
We will leave it at that because I will get totally off.
So, Bill Hansen and Ruthie are getting married in...
You said Cincinnati.
And Bill Hansen was a Whitefield Secretary working at Arkansas,
which is where Ruthie was from, right.
And they are getting married.
Reggie knew Bill.
And so he says, I am going to take the train from Swarth...
or from Cambridge.
Come with me.
And on the way back, we will go through the National Office and then come back up again.
Okay.
So, we take the train to Ohio.
I meet Ruthie.
Now, either his or her family was boycotting the...
because it was interracial.
So, Ruthie was black.
Bill was white.
I just remember that Ruthie said she had nobody to be her...
her maid of honor.
Now, I had never seen either of these people before.
They pour me into some little black dress.
They put heels on me.
And now, I've been in Gene Scurts all this time.
I've been in sneakers, right.
So, I have to fit into this little dress and then walk in these heels.
And I'm the maid of honor for this person I've never met before.
And then we go through the ceremony.
And then, on the way back, we get to the National Office.
So, I get to this office, which in my mind, I'm thinking is going to be like Urban League.
You know, with rugs on the floor and people dressed in little sluts and stuff.
Well, maybe not the suits, because I mean I had seen what the field workers looked at.
But, see, in my mind, I'm thinking also this is a National Office.
So, they're probably dressed differently.
So, I get to the office, was it 8 1 1 2 and a half, 6 1 1 1 1 2 and a half rainmasthread, I think.
But anyway, 8 1 1 1 2 and a half rainmasthread, which was a side street,
off Hunter.
Not Hunter wrote.
God, what was the main drag that's now Martin Luther King drive?
Are you sure it's not Hunter?
Oh, maybe it is, it's Hunter.
Yeah, it's Hunter, which is now Martin Luther King Boulevard.
So, you went down, it was right near the Atlanta University Center,
and you'd go off to the right if you were coming from downtown.
And, it was a small street.
And, it was right next to either Beauty Parlor, I think it was a Beauty Parlor.
And, it was like a door, we call it Glass Door.
And, I see Reggie get to the door and there's this guy at the top of the stairs,
and he's sweeping the stairs.
He's in overalls.
I hear Reggie, you know, hollering and whooping hollering, and either he or the guy says,
hey, Captain, how you doing?
And, they hugged like long last brothers, right?
And, I'm thinking how egalitarian, egalitarian is SNCC because this is the custodian, right?
And, then I find out it's Jim Forman, the executive secretary of the organization,
and he is sweeping as he often did, because it really was a lesson for him.
It was everybody in SNCC needed to see him sweeping so that they knew that every job was important.
And, yeah, you were supposed to cleave it as clean as you could, the office.
And, secondly, that no job was too lowly for anybody in the organization to do.
So, he would periodically sweep the stairs, not very well, let me just say.
But, he would do it.
Okay.
So, then I come up, Reggie says to him, I'm coming from Swarthmore, we're on our way back to Cambridge.
Forman finds out that I can take shorthand, which is like, I try and tell people it's kind of like texting, but with symbols.
So, everything had a symbol that we did.
And, I knew I had learned this, and could type 90 words a minute.
Both of those because, um, Tarrytown Public Schools, when I'm at Washington, Irving, Junior High School, in seventh grade, because I'm black.
And, it really was that, because I was at the top of my class.
They shift me into secretarial, assuming that I'm going to do the secretarial route.
Okay.
Now, at that point, my sister, hello, is at Bennington, but that's okay.
And, so, and also, under the hill, you know, it's, I mean, it's all that stuff.
So, my mother makes sure that it's only that year.
She, I do remember her being very upset when she heard that I was being shifted into this.
So, I either took the whole semester in the seventh grade or the whole year, either way.
I now can type 90 words a minute, and I can take Regshorthand.
So, um, they should, and they're older, well, let me not get, okay, so, um, yeah.
And I'll get to Joanne Grant, and my shorthand notes when I'm taking it in SNCC.
But, so, Forman finds this out, and then decides I'm going to be his secretary.
So, Regge goes back to Cambridge alone.
So, my trick Cambridge.
I leave my clothes there. I don't remember what happens with the clothes.
They probably stay in pop herbs. You know, I don't know what happens.
And then I go into the Freedom House, which is where the female staff, some of the female staff, from the National Office lived.
But, my first image of-
So, it was fall 63.
That's correct. And the reason I remember it was November was because the first staff meeting I remember was, um, and we had called in,
it wasn't just the Atlanta National Movement staff. It was also the, um, the field staff.
And Kennedy had just been shot.
And so, there's this whole discussion about how we're going to respond to it, particularly given that the federal government hasn't done deadly squat for us and stuff.
And I remember Forman saying, you know, we have to be very careful about this.
I remember Dinky crying.
Um, Dinky who was, Forman's second-
becomes later on, Forman's second wife.
Um, but I remember her being the only one who was crying, actually.
I'm sure there were others, but most of the people were really trying to figure out how do we respond to this strategically.
So, um, so yeah, that's how I remember I was there by November.
I remember something about that wedding.
Hmm.
Puffington? Puffington.
Is that Lucy's name?
I think that might be. I don't remember.
I don't know. Um, it seems like I remember you telling me something about that wedding, like, something in a week ago, or something.
Oh, or anything.
No. Okay.
I might have once remembered it, but I don't know.
I don't remember either.
Okay.
So, yeah.
What was, um, what was your job with Forman as Forman's secretary?
Yes.
Well, I'll tell you before I get to that, let me tell you what, when you came into the Atlanta office, okay?
When you first came in, you came up the stairs from the, with the plate, you know, with the window behind you.
Come up the stairs. If you, you came into the, the kind of reception area.
And that would have been, um, uh, you would have seen, oh gosh.
I remember his name before Jimmy Bolton. Thank you.
Yes. Jimmy Bolton was there.
And he was one of the few guys.
Now, Jimmy was the only person who was overtly gay.
I'm sure there were other people, male and female, but he was the only one who, who didn't really try and hide it, you know.
And then there were other people at the two desks.
And Jimmy, by the way, eventually goes off with his mate to Australia.
But at that point, he's, he's Jimmy and it's, um, maybe Nancy Stern, other people, other people, because we took turns being reception at the reception area.
If you went off, if you looked to the left, you would see, um, Julian Bond, and he was communications director.
When I get there, Mary King is his assistant.
Um, then, yeah, I'm, we didn't have titles, but she was, Julian was the communications director.
So when I get there, Doddy, Zellner had already left who had been the previous, um, person assisting Julian and communications.
But so it's Julian and it's Mary King. It's, um, Bobby Yancy, who becomes the second and command at the Schomburg later on.
Um, it stays there for 25 years, but is, you know, is at that point, she's head of, um, I think relationships with the age, now is known as the HBCU is the black campuses.
There was Billy Stafford campus travelers. That's right.
Um, and so she's head of that, the campus travelers. Thank you.
And then there is Billy Stafford, who was doing some other work with black campuses. And Billy later goes to, um, his wonderful social, urban planner at, um, city college in New York.
But, um, at that point is doing work something around, um, black colleges, but I can't remember exactly what.
And then, um, there is Jack Menis, who was the main person, he was the head of, of our research department.
And we had this incredible, I mean, he was incredible. You know, he is, he is this crusty, old white guy who, excuse me, drank too much, smoked too much.
You know, you would go in his office. It was like a fog. It was like China, you know.
Um, and yet he could pull research from a stone. So can, can I mention the thing? Okay.
There was something he did, which became a, um, this is the Mississippi chronology. And it's a chronology of, um, it's called the Mississippi chronology of violence and intimidation in Mississippi since 1961.
What Jack did was he compiled all of these pages with photos and what was called Watts line. So that was the wide area telephone service. That was like the 800 number that people call into at any hour, either at to our national office or to one of us in the national office.
If a church were being bombed or, um, somebody had been arrested, um, some violence to vote registration workers, they would call in. And the Watts line meant that it was somebody, and this is when you still had operators.
So somebody say it's, um, uh, Emma, uh, Emma Bell. And Emma Bell calls and says, Hollis Watkins has just been arrested, but she can't say that she calls and calls person to person for Hollis Watkins.
Okay. And so Hollis Watkins, we know. Oh, so that's how it's walk in season. The second CD, second congressional district. We know the number. We know it's about hot.
Oh, no, no, I'm sorry. Mm-hmm. She would say I'm calling for Emma Bell. Okay. She would call for herself. And then she'd say, this I'm calling a person to person to Emma Bell.
We would say, this bell is not here right now. Is there a number where we can reach her? And then we would know to call her back. What happened is that at a certain point, the old white operators, telephone operators in Mississippi realize what we were doing.
They would then cut off when she's, when the person's tried to give the number. But until that, we at least always had the name. Okay. So then we would hang up and then on this 800 line, the watch line, we would call back for free. She, um, and, and find out that Hollis Watkins was in jail or somebody had been, you know, church had been burned or whatever.
Um, those watch line reports are, are the reports that are compiled for that Mississippi chronology. And I'll go ahead. Okay.
The reason that was so important, having a chronology was that it showed the pattern of racial, of white supremacy. So nobody could say, well, it was just Governor Thompson. He's particularly racist.
Or it was this, this sheriff in Greenwood or the second, you know, it's the system of racism. And you show that through the pattern of all of these churches, all these people being beaten for voter registration.
The, the systemic nature of the white supremacy. And then what they've done to basically, supposedly federally protected rights, just one rough shot over them, right.
I will say I use that. I used it not only to give a chronology when we're doing the films, but more particularly when I leave, um, Boston the first time and it's L.A.
And there's yet another case of police brutality in L.A. And I'm working for a film company rainbow TV works. This was 80 to 81 82.
I know from Jack Minnes' chronology. So I say to the people who are working on this, we need a chronology so that we can say so that we can show the pattern of it. And to them, it's like, oh, what a good idea.
You know, I would not have known it had it not been for minutes. Okay. When I'm working as the director of information of the United Church of Christ, commission for racial justice, you know, and there's a spade of police brutality.
You know, it's how the power beach racially motivated violence. It's, you know, Elana Bumper is 69 years old, gets off by officers Sullivan with a shotgun on an eviction notice. It's Michael Stewart, you know, 20 for your age old gets beaten to death in a, in a, for doing graffiti in a New York City subway. It's all of that.
But what I say to the committee that we're working with is we need a chronology. Minnes, right. We need a chronology to show it's not just the cop hasn't had enough, you know, sensitivity training. It's because he's in the midst of a systemic racist police department, right. It's like what they're doing. Anyway, so.
What's the guardian is doing now? You got it. That's right. Because the NRI won't let us keep any stats of this country, right. So the UK is keeping the best stats. Hello.
Which is why I'm glad by the way that in Chicago, I'm going far, I feel bad. I was going to say this. Why in Chicago, they have gone back to that brutal man who tortured blacks.
And then you know, got finally put up for charges. And I think may have spent some time. I'm not sure. But he is legend. And people kept talking about him because he was brutal. He tortured people.
And got you know, how it got got guilty, please from them when they weren't guilty. We did an eyes on the prize, the Hampton and Clark, Fred Hampton, Mark Clark assassinations in the second series of eyes on the prize, which people are now harkening back to because that's another case where you know the cops said, oh, we had to protect ourselves.
And they found out that all of the bullets were going inside the black panther Chicago office, all of them because the cops were stupid enough to leave the office open. So people in the communities walking through the media is walking through right anyway, the main thing.
And this is the from eyes on the prize second series, the episode of Nation of Law. That's correct.
And so this is important because one of the things you get is the pattern of it. You know, people always wonder, well, why are they going off? You know, it's like in Detroit. Why would they go? Why would the black community go, you know, totally berserk because some cops are closing a what's called a blind pig there.
And after hours joining, that makes absolutely no sense. Well, if you go back and you find out there was the big four to white and to black cops, which would stop all of these people, even if they were just singing do up, you know, this Detroit, right.
Do up. We had to explain all of that and eyes on the prize because otherwise it makes no sense. It's the pattern, the systemic pattern of police brutality that always exists in any of these cities. And it's always, always the jumping off point.
Always, it's something on Steve Faire, who was the white writer and just a great guy. I mean, I, we clashed sometimes, but he was really serious about his stuff and a great writer.
So I remember at one point we're doing Malcolm X make a plane, right, for American experienced PBS. And I say, you know, the point is that, you know, when you're doing Malcolm, what happens in LA, what happens in New York with the Muslim guy from, you know,
the food of Islam guy from number seven mosque, you know, that's part of a pattern. And he said, and he actually said, because he was interested, you know, he said, what do you do? I said, the police are an occupying force in these communities.
And I said, no, I know you can't say that. And now he said, why not? And it's a line in narration, right. And you say, that's black side.
And yeah, black sign. And also I wasn't sure with Orlando, whether Orlando, you know, would be okay with that because it's enough that we're doing just to say enough that we're doing Malcolm X make a plane.
Sorry, I meant when you said we were doing the film, I meant it was black side that was doing it.
Right. No, I thought you were going to say something else in the middle. No. And yes, it is black side. But it's, it's, it's, Henry was not that much involved in Malcolm X make a plane.
So it really is Orlando was a producer director. I'm the co-producer and Steve is the series writer along with Orlando. So it really is, you know, what, what Orlando and Steve feel, you know, we can get through, you know, American experience at that point.
So I was very happy, you know, that people could see it's an occupying force. And actually I think I said, occupying army. It's like an occupying army.
But that has to do with back to this chronology and the fact that it's systemic and that you have to show that. And so in fact, when we're doing the police brutality, I did a chronology, right. And I'm saying to the groups that are there.
We need to do a chronology. So people see us not just Ellen or bumpers is not just Michael Stewart is not just. And so they give me early stuff because this is now the mid, this is the mid 80s. So they go back to the 70s, the 60s.
I draw up a chronology. I remember sending a packet out to a journalist, a reporter, black journalist who was with New York News Day.
Because they were based in Long Island, but they then had a New York edition. And they were really good. It was a great, it was a great paper.
And the reporter calling me and saying, you know, I'm getting this packet and it was not only the press release, but this chronology. And he said, are you a reporter?
And I said, no, I said, and what I said was, I was trained by the movement. I didn't say SNCC, because I figured he wouldn't know what SNCC was. But I said, I was trained by the movement. And so I said, in one of the reasons I did the chronology was because, I didn't say, because Jack Menace told me how to do this, you know. But it's always good. And I was meeting with some young people.
Oh, BSO, organization of black, oh my goodness, no, OBS, not organizational black survival, organization of black something, it's OBS. And it's a group that's been going on for the last 20 some years. And they were involved also in the Ferguson responses.
But they do grassroots community organizing struggle organization for black struggle. So I had been showing our Orangeburg massacre film at Washington University. This is right after Ferguson. So it was this year.
And I'm showing the film and one of the professors, a young black professor, who was there and postdoc and he came up, he introred me. And then he said, would you be interested in speaking with some of the young people who are part of this organization of, what did I just say?
It'll be a box struggle. And I said, oh, yeah. So the day that I'm the next day, he brings some of them by Wash You and we sit in the cafeteria and we're talking and it's clear. I said, look, I know that the stuff what we did in SNCC is not really, you know, some of it will be useful. But it's a different time.
And I know that it's not just the technical stuff. It's you're dealing with the community that has seen all the stuff that was supposed to change stuff and it hasn't. And the other thing they told me was, they said, well, the other thing is, and actually the young professor said, wasn't professor.
Anyway, the young faculty person said, and the other thing was that the movement kind of bypassed St. Louis. So the kind of folks you talk about with, you know, Amsy Moore and Fanny William, he said, that didn't really happen here. And one of the people from OBS says to me, look, every king day, they have the usual Dr. King ceremony. And the black glitterati, come past, you know, and he said, she said, as a matter of fact, she said, and they get out of their limos.
And she said, I call them the furcoated ones. And she said, they come out with their furcoes. They go into whatever big black church. And then they come back and they go back to the suburbs or wherever. And she said, and so we don't have that grounding that maybe you guys did at that time.
Now, I'm sure that their grassroots leaders they have there, but, and they've been working with them, but, you know, it made me realize not everybody had the kind of stuff that we had, nor the kind of cohesive communities that we had cause for whatever I may be not churched. But I know the role of the black church played in the Southern communities where we organized. And, you know, and you could go up on somebody's porch and sit for a while and have some sweet tea and talk before so they could get to know you.
You can't do that. A cabrini green when it was still existed. You know, in Chicago, so all of that stuff I know is different, but I show them Jack. I show them the chronology right. And I said toward the end, this gets the St. Louis young people in St. Louis and one of one older because she was like 40s. So she said, I'm the older person here. I show them this. They were so it was like, we could use that.
Because I said, you know, one step people see it's not just this and it's not just that and it's not just for any grain. It's like history of it, you know. And it's like when they're finally now saying that like 99% I'm making this up, but certainly over 95% of the cops that have been put up on charges never go to trial. You know, because, you know, they just, it never goes anywhere. So to know that kind of stat from the sixth century, I mean, I mean, I'm sure that's the kind of thing that I'm going to do.
So I'm going to do that kind of stat from the 60s and the 70s, how, how many cops get put up, how many cops, how many judgments are found. And when somebody said $15 million has been put out to victims, all that stuff, those stats are important. Yeah, you can have the protest. And that's important too, but those stats are you can't, you can't deny that kind of stuff. That's Jack. I learned that in, in SNCC, you know. So he's doing the research department.
Back to the national. We get, we have a, we have a printing press. And so, oh, my goodness. I can't remember the guy Wilson Brown. He was one of them. And then there was another one who married. And they, they went to Antioch. Oh, my goodness, who also ran it. But I'll do Wilson until I can remember any. We had our whole printing press in the basement. Right. So that we didn't have to depend on anybody.
Saying they wouldn't deprint, wouldn't print a certain leaflet had our own printing press. And then we had, so through communications, we're also sending out the student voice.
Because we knew that the mainstream media wasn't going to print it stuff that we wanted. So we would send that out to the SNCC offices. And so I forgot. We also had a, a friends of SNCC, which was like Philadelphia, Mimi, Mimi,
Mimi Shaw's mother, Mrs. Shaw's head of friends of, is part of friends of SNCC in Chicago. Or they're all over the country. And so if somebody got arrested, for example, then we get that watch line report, then we would call the Justice Department in the National Office. And then we would call a friends of SNCC person.
So, for example, you would call Mrs. Shaw in Chicago. And she would then call the Sheriff's Office if we had it, well, his home at night, if we had his number, or the office. And then that person would say, Mrs. Shaw would say, look, we know you got, you know, Curtis or Hollis or Mrs. Fanny, Mrs. Hamer. And they'd better come out of the jail the way they went in.
So you had, for the first time, the white supremacists in Mississippi know somebody outside, Mrs. Cippy is actually looking at this, you know, even before the summer of 64. We're connecting people to this.
So we have somebody coordinating, Frances SNCC, and that was Dinky Constante, or Romali. And then there was, she was also doing campus friends of SNCC until Betty Garmin comes in, and she does the campus friends of SNCC.
And that was all the campus chapters. UC Berkeley and NYU, University of Chicago, all these campus things. So we can call them. So they're being used as points where we're getting information about the struggles that we're doing.
We're getting photos out. We're getting the student voice out. Press releases is going out. They're trying to get published in their school newspapers information about it.
If they have any contacts with the local media, they're trying to get that in. So it's this network. I mean out of the national office are these networks of people all over the country whom we're using for fundraising for communications.
And for fund, yeah, fundraising communications and whatever else.
What's your contact like with people in the field in Mississippi and Georgia or Pennsylvania?
Yeah, they were, they're calling in. So when, for example, a rebel calls in, she calls into us. But also we had, Margaret Block, for example, she said to me, you remember, I had to call into you. She said, every, every day.
And during the summer of 64, they're calling in to the Jackson office. But before that, they're calling into the national office.
And I think we might have done it once a day until 64, when it's twice a day, and going into the Jackson office.
But once a day into the national office to say, this is what happened to make sure we know they're still there.
And the main thing is, you know, there's before cell phones. So if somebody didn't have a dime for the coin box on the phone, you wanted to make sure they could get to you.
So it's called, they're calling in, they're telling us, you know, maybe something incident that's happened.
But the other thing was, Ruby Dars was serious about, you will get me your monthly field reports. And unless you send those to me, you will not get your little $10 a week, which was of course $9.64 after taxes.
So she was, I mean, Ruby, and the thing is, people really respected Ruby because I remember Ivan was saying, he said, yeah, people respect a former for what he brought, which was that administrative sense, knowing about history, collect everything.
Knowing how to construct an office, and also just that long range thinking. But Ruby, he said, we knew she really, really cared about us.
And Ivan, who once said to me, he said, you know, when I was in jail, and that was probably an apartment, he said, and I guess was Ivan, an apartment, I'm trying to remember, or was it a local jail?
When he went in with the trucker stuff, he was in Cleveland, because it was Amazee, that's right. No.
He was with Clarksdale, who was Aaron Henson, who was the drugs and the pharmacies. That's right. Was that the only time he was in? Maybe it was.
Okay, one of the times he was in, he said he was in for however long, and that he would get letters. Ivan, who said, every day.
And I said, how did you get them every day? He said, I don't know, but I was getting, he said letters from Ruby Daurus every day.
Asking how I was doing, just making sure that I knew somebody was taking care of me, was thinking about me and stuff.
And so Ruby would do that stuff, and also because, you know, she had such an amazing history. I mean, yeah, Jim Foreman, you know, had been just brutalized in LA, and you know, he had been in Monroe, and he had been this and that.
But Ruby had been in parchment, and Ruby had been in Rock Hill, South Carolina, and those 30 days jail, no bail.
And also, just Ruby, you know, was just, Ruby had a presence, you know. I mean, when Pennypac says to me, it's worth more, you got to go buy Ruby Daurus to get your application accepted.
I didn't really know what she meant, but I know that a lot of people were scared to death at Ruby Daurus. I was, you know, I mean, it was just, you know, she was nice, but she was kind of like Ms. Baker.
She did not suffer fools gladly.
Was she still a spell on the student when you met her?
No, she was totally off staff. She was full time in the office at that point. She had not yet married Cliff, and had not yet had the baby.
But, and that was funny too. I remember we had a shower for Ruby when she was pregnant.
And the thing is, you know, as an old female, right? And normally, I mean, people women know what to do at showers.
You know, you have a little chichad and the baby, and there's always a, we were snakewomen. All our discussions always had to do with politics, and what was going on in the field, and who was doing what?
And so I remember whole periods of silence. You know, it was like, okay, so how do we talk about this? You know, it's like the kind of informal, you know, it wasn't like we weren't friends. It wasn't like we didn't party. We knew how to party.
But to have small talk, we didn't do small talk too well. So, and we didn't do baby stuff. You know, it's like, I mean, Julian was a family member, but you know, he had his kids and Alice was all over the place.
Alice was off somewhere. She wasn't part of the staff. I'm trying to think minutes was married. I'm sure, but they were, you know, there were no babies.
So, it was different when the men are married and have their families and women.
Right. But also, I don't remember ever seeing Ruby's baby. I mean, I'm sure she brought it in at some point, but Cliff took care of the baby.
You know, and she was away, but when she was away, when she came into that office, she was in the office.
So, the shower was not, you know, she hadn't had the baby yet. And it was like, and none of the women that I remember had any babies. You know, nobody had any babies.
You know, how could you have babies when you were on call 24 out of seven? You know, it was like, anyway, so I just remember the silences at the shower.
So, anyway, Ruby, yeah, was, you know, she was just like a major force in that office. And she's saying, I need your reports, which is why I remember you're saying how interesting it was that you got, that there was so much documentation with SNCC.
And that's because, you know, you had Ruby Darryl saying you got to write it down and you're not going to get, I mean, oftentimes we didn't get the little $9.64.
But at least you could expect it, because I remember when I was in Cordial, Georgia, I didn't get it one week. And I had to go to the NA guy who really didn't like my being in town, Cordial in Southwest, Georgia.
And he ran the restaurant. And I had to say to him, could you just, I don't have enough money for hamburger. But could you just take this whatever little bit I had?
And he said, I remember saying something about, you know, I'll expect the rest when you get paid. He was not pleasant.
But I also remember putting a dime in, I spent 30 cents on his jukebox to play Walk On By, Deon War work. But anyway, so.
Just like being here.
Yes, there is. That's right.
That's right.
What is your day to day like in the office? What's your job with Farman?
Okay. So what's interesting to me is that Farman had a way of giving you as much responsibility as he thought you could take and more than you thought you could take.
I mean, there were times that he let me do things and I thought afterward, it's amazing that he let me do this.
But what happens is when I come in, I get this bird's eye view of the whole SNCC organization, the Francis, the campus friends, the SNCC, the field offices, the daily, you know, who's in the field offices?
Who's responsible? Who's not responsible? I'm taking minutes from the executive meeting, so I know who's in trouble.
I get a real sense of the field and all of the operation. And so I remember.
Did we set what碰 and job is?
Oh, I'm sorry. No, I may not.
Well, anyway, we didn't win. You made him with.
And he was the executive secretary. That's right. So Jim formed. Yeah, he's the executive secretary.
And he's in an office. I'm right outside his office with along with this teeny tiny little area. And Dinky Romley is the friends of SNCC and campus friends of SNCC.
And we're back to back and I'm at this little, little desk and Foreman's office is over here. And I think Chessie, Chesselonia Johnson, who is the bookkeeper, she poured Chessie.
I mean, that was a thankless job. I mean, it is thankless anyway within nonprofit, but we're, you know, it's the field staff say, I don't have to give you anything. You know, I'm putting my life on the line.
Okay, so it's all that coming out. So I'm sitting there and I have.
I remember letters to Michael, Mike standard, who was one of the lawyers in our pro, one of the many pro bono firms, our Benowitz and Boudin.
And we had this, I mean, we had this chatty relationship. And part of it is, you know, all these people are making feel that, making me feel that I really belong to this thing.
I mean, this is like this family of people. And so when I call Mike standard, it's like like attorney standard is, hey, Mike, how you doing? Did you do that?
And I had these things, you know, I said something to him were to him or somebody where I said, and we could not do what we do. And it was in fun.
I mean, and they knew I knew they would get we could not we hear in the South fighting for the there are freedom and our civil rights could not do what we do without you're doing what you did it.
And it was the kind of thing that you sent to a contributor, you know, and freedom now, you know, and then I would sign form and's name.
And then you would always know I was the one because it was the typical steno thing. So you would put Jim form and J F up all uppercase initial caps and then colon and then lowercase J R.
So I was a person who was typing it, but oftentimes I'm the one writing it too, you know, so which was amazing. I mean, he's given me this responsibility to write these letters.
So I'm writing, you know, letters to the so and so or to the so and so or, you know, and then sometimes I'm transcribing as well. So I remember transcribing a speech by,
Oh, did did did did pray for you. Thank you.
Pray for you. Who could I mean she could just lift you up, you know, so it's on a real to real recorder, right?
And I'm typing on this IBM select to which I love kids. Anyway, and she's doing it. It probably was not Southwest Georgia. It was probably Selma, but I'm not sure now.
And I swear to God, I'm typing on this typewriter and tears are just dreaming down.
Um, you know, it's like she's so captured me. She just lifted up. You know, she just she brought you to the place where you would go through hell to get your freedom.
You know, she would follow her anywhere, you know, somebody said to to about Praetia that, you know, even Dr. King once said when both of them were at a out of mass meeting that he did not want to fall.
He did not like following Praetia. Hi, Praes. Very high pray. And Praetia, you know, Praetia's parents were Pentecostal or evangelical, whatever ministers in a small black church in Philadelphia.
So she came out of that. And then when she passed, she had just taken the Martin Luther King chair at Boston University.
And, you know, she was very religious, you know, but she never let religion get in the way. So she in Selma really, you know, well, she never cursed.
But, you know, really points her finger at some of the SCLC people who say to the folks after bloody Sunday. And there's and she talks about her that in her hands on the Freedom Plow section. She says, you know, I told the SCLC, Dr. King's organization, Southern Christian Leadership Conference, they had some of the field staff had said to the local people, you can't come on the demonstration unless you're philosophically nonviolent.
Not just tactically, but philosophically nonviolent. And in fact, you are not really in the movement unless you can do this. And she said, I had to really get on their case because she said that was like blackmail.
And she said, and it wasn't true. And you don't do that to people. You don't use the movement in that way. Now, she was philosophically nonviolent. But she understood that, you know, you separate that stuff, you know.
But, you know, I remember, so I'm sitting there in the national office just typing a sub of tears pouring down. And I would, I would also transcribe, I would take the minutes for like executive committee meetings, executive committee meetings.
We would bring this the field staff in from Mississippi, Southwest Georgia, Alabama, you know, Arkansas. I don't, I want to say it was quarterly, but I'm not sure. So they would come in quarterly and they, we would always meet.
Normally, we couldn't meet, I don't think, at our offices because they were too small. The work room, because, oh, that's what I neglected to say. There was a work room. And so there's all this stuff going on. And then you would go into the work room.
I'm going to just divert for a second. You would go into the work room and there would be where you would put together press releases and staple them. And, you know, because at that point, the, the memograph machine didn't have a collater.
So it wouldn't automatically collate and staple later we get that. But right then it's pumping off the memograph machine and the stencil. And we're taking and Wilson Brown has taken it up.
And, you know, so we have it's a, it's a group of people and they're in the work room and you have all this stuff on the, on the table on the work table.
And somebody would take it off and hand it to the second person. Somebody stapling somebody collating, stapling, putting a folding it, putting it in the stuff, stamping it.
And so there's a relay. It's a, you know, thing.
Stemily line. That's the word I'm looking for. So it's an assembly line. So now we also had water bugs. So, and they were the flying water bugs that you get in the South.
So I say that to someone also by the way, if you were on the assembly line, you're always singing freedom songs. Because the work really does go quicker if you sing something.
And so, you know, everybody's singing and, and we're working and we're doing the stuff. Okay. Now on exec committee meetings, I would, but, but the work room was not large enough usually to hold the staff.
So we would then, we could get sometimes pass calls, although pass calls really was a black businessman. And so he would charge us. So we would go to Frazier's who really he was so lovely.
Frazier's basement. We would go down and how our meetings there sometimes. And he would feed you if you didn't have money, my pass call.
So, you know, you could ask who's in the Atlanta airport now and Frazier's, huh? Well, that could be. That's true. You know, one made money and one. Yeah. But what Frazier's was wonderful. They were just lovely. And, you know, you would go to pass calls for the, they had the bird cage. And so they would have, you know, what's his name in the pips. You know, and they would have all the R&B people come in. And sometimes you would get to meet them and they would be so.
So, excited to meet the kids and all that kind of stuff, but it was, it was a bird cage. That was a pass calls. But anyway, so I would be taking notes in short hand. Well, the first exact committee meeting I take, it's 33 pages. And it's 33 pages because I'm in awe of all these snake people. Right. They are.
33 pages. Type. No, 33 pages. Type.
After you took it in short hand, then you would type it. That's right. That's right. I would take it in short hand. And then I would transcribe my notes. I would type it onto these long green stencils. And which was a problem because, of course, the stencils you couldn't correct except with this little green fluid. So, you had to take the film up the screen up and then put the little green on and then wait for it to dry.
Put the film down and then hope that you hadn't put too much of this green stuff on because if you did, then when you put typed over it, it would smudge it. And you'd get these smudgy letters all over the place. So, so I was fairly accurate. That was the other thing. I could actually type 90 words a minute with pretty good accuracy.
Anyway, so I had 33 pages of notes, of minutes, pages of minutes typed out. And then I had to run them out. Now, the problem was I was there late at night. So I would sometimes be there during this period that I'm getting these minutes out. And again, I'm really in awe because these people know more than I have ever heard of.
Not only do I never talk in staff meetings, but I'm also just an awe of all these people who are talking about organizing in ways that I never thought about. They've been through stuff I've never thought about.
You got, you know, the howard, the nag people who are talking about, you know, Nietzsche. You know, I mean, it's like we're going through that. And also, you know, Biod Rustin and the Sons. But who have organizing techniques and then you've got the Southern young people who know Black History.
I know Black History in a way that I don't know. So it's all of this. All of this is combining to say, you shut up and take the minutes. Right. So I'm taking the minutes. Okay, get all these things.
But I have to, but it takes about a week. And I have it in my diary still taking the minutes. I mean, still, still typing the minutes, still typing the minutes.
Now, the meeting has since disbanded, right. And I think this was the one that we did at IPS, inter-denominational theological seminary, ITS, which was part of the, what becomes the Atlanta University system, inter-denominational theological seminary.
And so, okay, typing it up, I'm about to run it off and I'm by myself. So I have to go by myself into the workroom. Now, the workroom really does have these flying water bugs. They're big.
Is that a cockroach? It's like cockroaches, but I thought they were water bugs. Maybe they were cockroaches. They were flying cockroaches.
Okay, but they flew. That was the main thing. That was operative. Yes, that's true. But that's what the main thing for me was that they flew. What they were, it was that they flew.
And so they would be, you would come in and they'd be all on the floor. They'd be on the wall. And so you would have to steal yourself for, I'm going to go in here. I'm going to run this off. I'm not going to pay any attention to these things. And I'm just going to run this thing off.
Yes, if you had to, that's it. And you tried not to crunch anything. You see that's the other thing because it, okay, so doing that and then I finally got it and then I had to mail it, you know, to the various field offices. And that was the other thing.
And as a matter of fact, the day that I mailed it off, it's, I have in my diary, the sun is coming up. I have just finished doing the minutes. And I say the birds are singing. You know, it's a wonderful day.
And so I get that off to whoever was going to disseminate it in the field, you know, and stuff. And so I would do that. And then I would often take the minutes. And other people would too. But because I knew shorthand, you see and typed so quickly, you know, was like, well, Judy can do this because she does this stuff.
And then I would correct things, you know, because I've always been editing things. And, you know, I wouldn't edit the thoughts. And I don't even think I would actually back then I wouldn't even edit anything else. It would just be whatever I heard. That's true. Yeah.
So I wouldn't try, for example, finish the sentence or do whatever it was whatever they said got into it. Okay. So I would do that.
What else?
I didn't support anything else that was going on. Yeah.
So talking about the minutes, at a certain point, you and some of the other women have a little protest. Yeah.
The way I understand it.
You know, I'll tell you. That's right. So what happens is, um,
form it. See, I had been saying to form it. Form it. I want to go to the field. I want to go to the field. Okay. Which meant I want to go into Mississippi.
And in my mind, it was Mississippi because that's where all the action was. I knew about Alabama. I knew about Southwest Georgia.
But most of what we, what I was getting information about, you know, was, because it was Bob. And it was that whole Mississippi thing. It was Miss Bob Moses.
And that's where it was. Okay. So, um, I keep saying, I want to go to the field. And he was saying, no, um, when it happened, I mean, he did not want to lose a good secretary. Right. So, at one point I end up, oh, I know, he goes someplace.
And Dinky got me a ticket for the, um, the first freedom day in Hattiesburg. That's right. So January, Hattiesburg, 64, Hattiesburg. I'm down there. And I come back for me. It was living.
But then at some point in here, I get tired of taking the minutes. There were other women who got tired of the minutes. But also they kind of I think wanted to be in the field too.
But also it was like, we get the secretarial stuff. Now, aside from Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy Bolton, um, the guys, see, the thing is the, the, the national office was where you put white people.
Because white people really risked the lives of local communities and local and and and other blacks and the staff people if they were working in Mississippi.
You know, um, Sherrod wanted an integrated staff in Southwest Georgia, right? Because he wanted to model what this thing could be.
And philosophically, he absolutely believed that and he believed that it was based on his, his theological understanding of what was supposed to so beloved community meant you didn't your project as well.
Other folks were not playing them. And because it really did risk lives. So, um, so what it meant though was that for white people who want to be involved, oftentimes particularly white women who could get black guys killed.
In the field, um, they were then in the office. So Mary Kings in the office, you know, um, uh, Casey's in Jackson, but she's in Jackson. Casey Hayden is in Jackson.
But mainly you didn't really have any white women in the field except for Southwest Georgia. And, um, so dinky's there. Nancy Stern is there white women in the national office.
Um, Mary King. Mary King. Oh, I thought I mentioned her. Yes, Mary Kim. Yeah, that's right. Um, and even for Mark Zucker. I mean, he's not there. He's doing some print stuff too later on when Tommy O'Walkiama comes. Oh, and that's the other part that's part of the national office is the field. There's a print photo department.
And so Danny line is there. And then Tommy O'Walkiama, who was Tom then, but as part of the nationalist thing where people are really going back to their heritage, right. Tom, Tommy O, then Tom is Japanese Canadian, right. And so he goes to Tommy O. And so that's what he's known out, not known now as as a really premier photographer and has exhibits and wonderful photo book and stuff. Okay. He's, he gets, he comes in through, um, he's doing a lot of work.
And he's a book that he says similar to elders, cleaver, cleaver's, um, so long ice. He's called Tommy O is calling his book, so long rice. Yes. So he's doing this book. And he mentions how, um, he, he talked at our snake 50th about how he could, I don't know whether you can use us or not. No, don't worry about it. So anyway, he comes into snake through Birmingham. And he arrives in Birmingham. The day that the four little girls are killed.
He cooks up because there's a, there's a black person in where he lands who says, son, you really don't need to be around here. You need to go to this hotel and stay there because I don't know what's going to be happening. He gets there. He finds Foreman and Danny Lyon and Julian Bond.
And Foreman says, and, and they find out that he wants to join the movement. And so they, Foreman says, do you have a car? And Tommy O says, yeah, I got a little bug. He said, fine, you can drive us down to the national office. So from Birmingham to Atlanta.
Tommy O says that for the first week or so, Foreman has him sleeping the floor. And finally, he gets, I had for no money, by the way, because he's not even on staff at that point.
Tommy O says he looks at Foreman. At some point says to Foreman, you know, I really would like to do something else. And so Foreman then puts them in. I don't know whether Tommy O already knew some stuff around photography. I don't remember.
In any event, he's then goes into photos. And so then he becomes part of the photo department. So he's down there as well. And how did I get off into photo department?
Tell us about the minutes. Oh, yes. So, so all these other people are the guys are doing this other stuff, right? But none of the women except for, you know, Mary King is working with Julian and communications. But generally, we're not going in the field. We're not doing other stuff.
And let me just say, I know why I shouldn't be in the field. I'm from Tarrytown, New York. I don't know anything about southern mores black or white. I don't know this stuff. I'm not church. You know, it's like, please, but you got it. That's it. I still want to go to the field because that's where the action is. Okay.
So, um, well, I didn't my own quiet way. So we decide. Foreman has gone away. Gone to, I don't know if it was when he went to the UK. I don't see. He goes to London for an anti-aparitate meeting at some point.
And that's that whole connection that Foreman brings around the South South African anti-aparitate stuff as well as African liberation stuff and Ghana and Kenya and all that stuff. So I'm aware of all of that when I come into SNCC for the first time.
But at some point, I know in my minute in my diary, I have that I'm going to meet Foreman coming from an international anti-aparitate meeting in London. And I'm going to meet him at the Atlanta airport and how excited I am to hear about, you know, I'm excited to think about what I'm going to hear from him.
But I don't know if that's that time because he used to go away. You know, he'd do fundraising meetings. He'd be at the Friends of SNCC stuff. In any event, he had gone away to some meeting and or fundraising party. And I, and we decide and I don't know how we get to this.
Ruby Dars, Dinky, Mary King, and who and I, and seeing me there was a fifth person, was somebody else in the picture? Oh, Bobbi Ansi.
And Mildred.
And Mildred and Bobbi Ansi.
Dinky's not your right. No, she wasn't in that.
And she wouldn't have been with Mildred as a matter of fact now that I think about it. Okay. So Mildred was Foreman's first wife.
Okay. So you're right. It is Mildred, Mary King, Bobbi Ansi, and Ruby Dars and I. And we made up little signs, little placards that said no freedom, no, no minutes till something comes, freedom's something. What was it?
Freedom comes to justice comes to Atlanta office.
That's it. That's right. And freedom now, you know what I mean? So we're standing up there and he comes back from whatever, you know, he comes back from the New York Times.
And he comes back into the office and he sees us in my little area with and we're sitting on the floor with our little protest signs.
And he is behind us because clearly I think it was Danny. I'm sure it was Danny who takes his photo.
So it's a staged photo, but it's after Foreman comes back and sees us sitting and saying, because I think Foreman's in the back of the picture with a sign.
Oh, I don't remember him having a sign, but he is. That's why I was saying he's in the back, but I don't remember him having a sign, but I'm not sure about that.
Yeah, I don't know that we would have let him have a sign, but I don't know about that. And I would need, I actually have a copy of that.
So we do that. Now what's interesting about that is that when Foreman does the second edition of making of a black revolutionary in his second edition, he says that his editor, and I can't remember, she was a SNCC staff person. I can't remember who.
No, not white female person. I can't remember who it is. I may or may not remember it. Anyway, says to him that he should do more on the Women's Liberation Movement.
And so he does a section. And in it, he says that, a woman says, you should talk about this and I talk about the sit in your office. And he says in this intro.
So I talked to the women in the office. And I, and no, no, he said the women in the office came to me and asked me what I about how they could best do this, you know, get, come to the attention of the men in the organization.
And I suggested that them they do a sit in in my office, says, for him. And usually what I'm saying is I actually have the book because I read from it. And what he says is, so I suggested they do a sit in and that they do placards and that they do this, you know, sit in and it will come to the, you know, the attention of the guys.
Okay, now he comes out with this next edition while I'm in Boston working on the second, let's see, that came out in the 80s, I guess, mid 80s. So I'm working on think on the first series of eyes on the prize, I think.
And I'm reading this on the train. And I see this section and I still have in my copy what an exclamation point, exclamation point in blue highlighter.
So I get down there to the book party and I wait till the end and it's just, it's just he and I at the end. And he saw me in my book and I said, for him.
What are you talking about that you suggested this sitting, you know the where the ones who did this, he said, well, that's not what I remember.
It's like, so what do you say behind that? You know, now fast forward, we're at the snick 40s and Jackson. And was that, I think it was a Jackson, wasn't it?
It's a 40s, it's a Duke. Duke was a Duke, we were at Duke, you're right. And I'll line a panel with Ivan Ho and Foreman and somebody else.
And I'm sitting next to Foreman. And Foreman starts talking about this and he looks over at me and he says, and I know that Judy has another interpretation of this.
And I said, no, I have the facts. I said, but you're telling the story now. So you get to go. You know, it's like, what?
So it was interesting because at the same time that this is happening, I also felt the most powerful I've ever felt.
I always felt that I had no limits. You know, the people let me do, and it really was let me because I had no real power.
You know, it's like, they let me, they let me do stuff that it went like the residential freedom school. I come up with this idea after 64.
Let's do a residential freedom school. Now, it means that it must have been actually, it must have been sometime in 65.
Because I'd already been to Cordial Southwest Georgia. And I've been the staff person there. And so anyway, I come back with this idea.
We'll get, and my thing was, okay, we'll get the energy of the southern kids and the sense that you really can change things.
And together with some of the young people who are associated with the Friends of Snick Offices. And so we ended up going through in Rocharp, who was head of the Chicago Snick Office then.
And so we based it out of Chicago for the northern end. And then we were going to go back to Cordial for the southern end.
We were going to do three weeks in one place and three weeks in the other. And the idea was that we would have a whole curriculum.
And, okay, I had this whole idea about what would happen. And the northern kids, the advantage of putting these together is that you get the energy of the southern kids.
And the northern kids' reality of this is just up south. And there would be this kind of inter...
You'd have this... there's a word for that. Interaction, yes. So I come up with this idea. And I remember Ivan was saying to me, yes, interesting. He said, why don't you put it down? Let me see a draft of the proposal. Maybe I can see if I can get it funded.
And he says the same thing. Also, the stokey says, stokey says, yeah, let me know when you want me to come and I'll come up. Charlie says the same thing.
Nobody says to me, you have never done this before in your life. What the hell do you think you're thinking of?
If I had been those other people, I would have said, no, no, no, no, no, we're not giving this to you. Nobody says this. Nobody ever said this to men or women.
There was a sense that if it seemed like a halfway decent idea was part of the agenda of the organization.
That you know, go for it. And so I haven't ho, somehow got this funding because I know I didn't. I knew how to write a proposal.
Or I knew I must have seen proposals written because I certainly didn't know coming off Swarth and West Campus.
So I learned all this stuff in how you do this in SNCC. And I do this, but again, it was go for it.
And this is, I don't know, when you have Charlie Cove.
That's right, it's the Stokeley Carmichael. That's right.
So, yeah, it was the sense of being limitless within the agenda of the organization, the philosophy of the organization.
And if you got people to support you, I mean, you couldn't just decide to do this.
Clearly, there was some support that had come through somewhere, probably, on Chaudh by Ivano.
That had allowed me to go ahead and move with this.
I know that at a certain point, you're in the Atlanta office and you participate in a couple different sit-in.
Oh, yeah.
One's at the Tattle House.
And then there's another one where you get arrested and get some publicity.
Or you just get some publicity.
See, I got arrested several times in Atlanta demonstrations. That's the thing.
So, I'm not sure which one was associated with the rest, but the one, if I remember correctly.
And I'm pretty sure this one was right. The one at the Tattle House.
The Tattle House was like a, a, a, a, a, a, a, show needs bigsboy in Atlanta or, or Wendy's.
It was a restaurant chain like that, like I hop.
And so, we were trying to get them to integrate.
Well, that particular day, Foreman had found out that Oginga Oginga, who was at that point, I think,
foreign affairs officer from Kenya, may have had other things, but under, under, I think, Jomokanyata.
And so, you know, this is newly independent Kenya.
And so, he's this high ranking diplomat.
And he's now in Atlanta. And Foreman finds out, because Foreman really kept aware, you know,
was very much aware of the international relations part when it came to African affairs and, yeah, African affairs.
So, he finds out Oginga Oginga is going to be star staying at the Peach Tree Manor,
which it only a year before had been integrated.
Because it was that whole thing about, you know, Atlanta, the city too busy to hate.
And, you know, it had become really embarrassing for the federal government in this cold war,
where, cold war time for these newly African nations to send diplomats into the South,
and they couldn't eat at restaurants, right? Really bad, bad publicity,
particularly because this was the time when Russia really was major.
So, major force, it's the cold war.
This country wants these newly independent African countries to go onto the side of the United States,
and not on the side of Russia.
So, how the U.S. looked with all of this horrible, you know, segregation and stuff,
was a black eye.
And, of course, Russia was taking, you know, as Vestia would put headlines when the Birmingham bombing,
church bombing, everything.
Okay. On top of which, the African diplomats are coming driving down Route 40 before there's a highway 95,
and Route 40 was the direct line between New York City, their chancers,
and the embassies in Washington, D.C. So, they would come down.
They would not be able, once they left, really, once they hit Delaware,
they couldn't really, and actually they couldn't even eat even a chester,
a chester Pennsylvania, because chester Pennsylvania was segregated too,
but they get down and they can't stop anywhere.
Right. So, the U.S. is really, the federal government is not happy, you know,
and so, that whole line of particularly Route 40 and then going into Atlanta is not looking good.
So,